hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and I'm happy to be
back
I haven't streamed for a while I was on
vacation last week and today we're gonna
work on our search feature which we
haven't worked on in a really long time
so we got it to a point where it works
but it didn't have all the functionality
that we wanted so now I want to go back
to it and take a look at it you know see
if we still like it and what we need to
do is to get it to a point where we're
really happy with it and it'll be good
for a user yeah so in the chat I guess I
I haven't I haven't talked with you it
feels like such a long time so if
anything new is going on let me know in
the chat I'll definitely check that out
you know in between coding and also just
a heads up I'd like to keep this stream
under an hour
I might have a meeting at 3 p.m. my time
which is about an hour from now so just
in case I do have that meeting I want to
make sure I'm ready for it
so I'd like to keep that you know maybe
give me like 10 minutes to prepare
because if I do have a meeting I'll
probably have to present some data that
I did not get yet hey iniki's here how's
it going
Syd Syd haurache sorry if I'm
mispronouncing the name let me know if I
am please
anyway how's it going all right so let
me get started in case I have some new
people here I'll just do a quick recap
of how we made this the search function
and let me put it up on the screen here
there we go
sorry if the picture is not as good as
normal I left my my webcam in my
backpack and I left my backpack at home
I had a doctor's appointment this
morning and just was going to be late
and just ran out the door without at all
but I think it'll do you all don't watch
this for my face anyway so this screen
will still look good the code will look
good so here's our search page and I'm
just running this locally but if you
want to check this out
live you can go to dev dot Franciscan
University and I should let me let me
just paste this in to the live chat now
and then that way you all can check it
out so the dev the version running on my
computer and the version running here at
this URL that I just put in the live
chat exactly the same version in terms
of this page so you should get the same
results that I'm getting here and so
let's just let's check this out
cool yeah so you see I as I type things
change there we go
so I get different results as I type and
right now the results show up with a
category so our categories here are
basically our post types that we've set
up in WordPress and I'll show you a
little bit about about that in in just a
few seconds here and then we have the
title and it looks like yeah it looks
like some of these titles still could
use a bit of work I have had some
student workers helping out with
cleaning up the data which is really
nice so it looks like the rest of these
look really good so others have to check
on some of these things because
obviously we don't want three PLU four
Pharmacy asterisk right that's that's
not good
so probably don't need that at all that
piece of content but right now some of
the links work so we've made the title a
link doesn't really look like a link so
we might need to style that differently
but if we click this it should take us
maybe is it gonna work okay it is it's
working now so that's weird
actually this is really weird I thought
we had styled this so that it should
work let's check out another faculty
member let's just say died here we go
Monica's okay so all right I need a
little bit of work on styling I'm glad I
saw that because I thought we had these
styled pretty like okay across the board
so let's go back we'll stick with this
search page for now so let me type in
since I know biology works I'll just
keep going with that because we get a
lot of results so we can search so if I
click sort whoa
aha Christopher I see you just put that
in there so Christopher already got that
era the sort was working and now it's
not so what did we do we haven't worked
on this for a long time so I'm not
really sure what we did that messes this
up from the files to find you might have
mixed up
I'm a type is invalid
and you list well at least we know where
to look okay I'm gonna start this timer
this Pomodoro timer so after 25 minutes
I'm going to take a break from the code
and I'm going to come back and answer
questions in the live chat
I will glance over occasionally through
the chat so if there's something really
important or you have if you see
something that I don't see that would
solve this problem I'll try to keep
looking over there so just put it in the
in the chat feel free to put any
questions in there and I'll get to them
after the session we might only do one
session today
it depends on how many questions we're
getting in the chat I do want to make
sure I can get all the questions as well
so let's follow this error message right
because we can't move on and add new
features if the features that we already
added aren't working right so first
things first let's check this error
message we need to go to menu list so
whoops let me rearrange my stuff here
well I'm gonna bring this over actually
I don't know what that window is so
these are the two I think we might use
this is our WordPress plug-in and this
window will be our this is our react
thing and this was some data had to
bring over don't save I had to bring
that over for a white list for that
University bulletin that I had showed
you on we'd worked on a bit and we're
actually white listing URLs or email
just as individually now which I'm not
thrilled about let's see menu lists menu
is
you know what I wonder if this is this
may have to do with material UI if I had
to guess I'd say that's it if you
remember maybe a month ago or so we we
upgraded significant upgrade to the
latest version of material UI and we we
had to make a lot of changes and I don't
know that I ever checked I may have
missed something in the components so
I'm guessing that might be it because I
can't think of anything else we change
that would affect this let's check out
our components though yes because we'd
only actually even have a menu list
component so that's referring to I'm
guessing something in in material UI so
what component trying to look through
this a bit to see if I can figure out
what components
alright let's just check out our search
component and see what we have see what
we're using here so we have menu item
we're importing menu item from material
our core menu check the render method a
menu oh I'm sorry
menu list
how about this list you know this girl's
probably too small I'm sorry about that
make that a bit bigger
all right so we're not actually using
menu list anywhere lists let's just try
list we're not even using lists at all
here
all right so what what components are we
using the layout component
see
all right this is a bit odd I guess I
was a good sign just to go over the code
of it to catch everyone up and just to
show you basically all we're doing here
you know we we have an input field and
then on on the ticket so unchanged I
can't remember what handler we use but
basically whenever we enter anything
into that search input it just runs a
let's see it runs this little API call
right so we fetch that and into this URL
string that we're creating we add in the
search term so it's not I mean it took
us a little while to get to this point
but it's you know at the core of it it's
just a basic API call to the WordPress
REST API I see some some help come in
here in the chat let me check this out
Sanjeet says press control shift F and
enter menu list to search that's search
for menu list and check its name from
yeah okay so Joseph it's an G both
saying search egg what was that control
shift F call I never knew the shortcut
to that I always just clicked it to open
it but it's a good idea menu list
a poor interesting what and that's the
only place oh man
check the render method of menu list
well I'm yeah I do not know all right so
we are getting some references to search
a s way down here 50 interesting it's a
250 and 250 249 in grid
okay
maybe maybe something changed with
material you I in terms of what I can
pass in here maybe this I'm guessing
here all right let's try something
flow control
hell protects
yeah I mean this this makes sense let me
go back let's see when this area comes
okay so as soon as I click it that's
when it happens so the air must be it
has nothing to do with the API call or
anything else rendering to the page it
must be with that the gist that section
that deals with that that select box so
I'm guessing whatever the problem is
it's it's here so let's check out the
material ID documentation for select and
see if something that we were doing is
now no longer supported and if it's not
obvious from the documentation we can go
back and check for all the versions the
previous versions and see if there are
any braking changes that were listed for
that we should be able to just you know
do a control fine and it shouldn't take
that long but first things first let's
check out materiai it should redirect
this was the URL for the latest version
it should tell me what version version
11.04 I don't remember what version
we're on let's check that out first to
make sure I knew I had my package JSON
open somewhere alright so let's see one
point 2.0
let's go go to the main 101.3 point oh
it looks like they've updated again so
we may need to update that soon for now
I'm just going to try to get this
working so let's just type in select and
see what we have
all right let's see so what first we'll
check select and then we'll kind of dig
down a menu item as well let's see so
we're using value on change and name
which I'm assuming or supported on
change value
so it doesn't list name here but I don't
think that would mess it up we can
always check a demo implementation
Ross is interesting we could use a
native select
change effects
all right I'm not seeing anything
terribly different right they are is
saying option let's go back to this one
instead of okay this one is usually menu
item okay
change input props so yeah for this menu
item we have a value and this looks like
it this looks like we could I mean looks
like it works right let me see how I'm
importing menu items then to you our
core menu and select yeah I mean I'll
make sure that I'm importing this
correctly
I guess whoops I could see it right here
and then you item I'm just gonna copy
and paste it it looks like it's the same
but oh you know what it is it is
slightly different
alright so let's see if that makes a
difference for us
okay well it's not giving us an error
anymore it's just not doing anything all
right so those buttons still work and
now we're not doing anything let me
check the console nothing getting
nothing
all right what did I do
I see a few more of you joined hey how's
it going
wow this is totally not how I expected
this would go but that happens okay so
what did I do I change the import of
menu item which shouldn't really have at
a difference here because we can see
that this is how it's showing that we
should import this we can go down here
and check oh we can check up here and
you check menu item
okay Christopher you will still be
getting that error because the change I
just made is only reflected locally so
at this point changes I make will not be
available let's check it out we we
didn't change anything here right and um
yeah it doesn't really tell us much
control over this like okay so we I
believe we are using a controlled
version of this so maybe maybe this will
show us the difference I'm close yeah
okay
this
okay all right I think I've found out
what we need to do so when you use this
as a controlled component which if
anybody's not sure what a controlled
component is let me know in the chat and
I'll take time to explain that but a
controlled component the value is
controlled by state so it was just
working before but now it looks like we
need to open and close this as well so
let's let's do that so we'll still have
our on change you know and we also need
a value of open which we had none of
those before okay I think this is it
this makes sense
based on what we're seeing so we really
had two problems first problem is we're
importing that incorrectly but then the
second problem is we now need to include
this in a newer version so let's also
add in these open and close handle is
here I guess we can put them in here and
we need in states I need to bring this
over and include it in our state there
we go
and see how that's gonna do me for fresh
mm-hm still not working we're not
getting in any errors related to that
alright let's check this out again all
harsh it saying use and rot we could
test it out yeah I'm gonna be a bad idea
at this point so that's open
actually it might not be a bad idea to
just check react
what's going on with reacts select okay
all right here's our values on change
you don't know gonna close the open is
set to true so if we click okay so
that's definitely not that's not
changing sum up how did it open get set
to true let's refresh this
okay that's quick true okay so we did
get truthful you know what we need
[Music]
clothes and clothes
oops I think I missed something here
let's see what they have in their handle
change this event target
maybe we need to switch to use this
input for ups as well
and I don't know why we need that ID
yep still nothing
interesting
like to see what what's rendering below
that
all right this is interesting
okay so we do have this rendering on the
page let the state exit interesting okay
my timer went up so I'm going to take
five minutes I'm going to go back here
to the chat and let's um I'm gonna
answer some questions now at least I
have a hint I'm sorry you know what this
was hidden y'all couldn't see that so
basically what I would have found in
here right is if if we go down there's a
modal at the root of this you know or
down or shouldn't say the root right
it's it's one of the children but anyway
when we go in here it doesn't really
matter whether we have this open class
of true or false
that's being passed down by props but
there's a state here of exited true or
false
and that's what really controls this so
somewhere along the way something's
changing so maybe I need to take a
closer look at how I'm supposed to
implement that component now with with
the newer versions so that's that's what
I'm gonna take a look at but for now I'm
gonna go to the live chat Phoenix says
hey Jesse you're back I tweeted you
today about the same glad to see you're
back oh cool Austin check check out
Twitter and thanks I'm glad to be back
our ketose says sup hey how's it going
see
how's it going hard [ __ ] hey Vinod Chris
asks do you have do you have to use
curly braces after name I don't know you
know what I noticed that in the
documentation they had some strings in
there and they were just using the
string and not the curly braces I'm not
sure why I put the curly braces here I
don't know if if I had to so that might
be something to check out although I
don't think this is an issue sorry it's
hard for the yawning there let's see
Nino says I just recently got a
contracting job thank you so much for
the help
hey no problem congratulations on the
job definitely let me let me know how it
goes
goo goo goo Raj says please explain side
nav as visible and hide to small devices
the side nav I'm not so do you mean in
general making a side nav visible and I
had on small devices or something we're
doing specifically on this project
because I mean I guess normally you
could achieve that through media queries
in your CSS Christopher Brown says have
you ever looked at switching to view no
I haven't looked at switching to view I
don't have anything against view I just
have a lot of projects and react and at
this point I kind of I would rather
specialized yeah so I mean you know to
do maybe a side project
than view just to try it out would be
cool but I have a lot of stuff going on
and react right now so I think it would
be I don't know I think I just think
it'd be better for me to specialize at
this point Nietzsche says no the curly
braces starts you enter JavaScript mode
and react yeah so that's why I'm
wondering if maybe those were necessary
in an older version all right I'm yeah
I'm not exactly sure why I added those
maybe I can take them out and it'll work
in any case I'm pretty sure that's not
gonna solve the issue but it may save us
a few characters okay
Nino says could you help me with the
layout yet Nino let me know just like
send me a message or something on
Twitter or you know that you know ask me
whatever questions you need to okay so
timers up it's it's 2:30 8 p.m. my time
so I don't want to do a whole nother
25-minute session because that'll put me
into my meeting time so let me check
for now yeah you know what for now my
next step is pretty much going to be to
just look through the documentation more
carefully which is not going to be very
fun for you all so I'm gonna just switch
up to checking on another part of this
and I'll read through the documentation
later so for now I mean these still work
so sorry these still work and the search
still works so you know we've got enough
functionality to go on here okay so I'm
not gonna restart that timer I'm just
gonna go for about I don't know 10 more
minutes with this actually yeah let's
sit a 10 minute timer go about ten
minutes and then I'll see what's going
on a live chat and I'll keep an eye on
if I start getting a lot of questions
I'll go back to the chat so what I'd
like to do is let's bring this back up
again what I'd like to do is make sure I
want to take a look at these these links
that we're creating because that's gonna
be an issue because not all of them will
work
Wow this is terrible if there's no way
this is gonna work yeah okay yeah for
sure that's not working all right so we
can come down here and look
where we have this
parents checkboxes ah here we are so
we're doing a lot of sorting right based
on what our sort it could be if our
check box were working so we don't need
to worry about this right now
what we have we're getting back JSON
data from our API call and obviously
reading back the title and the category
but we're also getting back the the type
and the slug and that's what we're using
to create our URL which it works
sometimes but not all the time so we're
gonna need more data we need more info
I'm wondering how we can do this
I think what we need
yeah what we'll need is maybe another
another filled in in WordPress and a
risk originally I was trying to get
around doing this but now that I have
some student workers I think yeah I
think it this can work we can actually
add a field so what may need to happen
then
yeah let me go to the WordPress where
sir that I thought I already loved into
one oh wow
okay let's go to major so that's what we
were looking at I think this so what we
need to do wow this is weird what the
heck happened here none of these even
have categories hmm that's no good off
to fix this let's go and click on one of
these then just to see what we have
alright so in particular yeah this this
is actually pretty awful there's not
even very much in there what we would
need then is a new field somewhat like
this permalink field where we can edit
this link but what we'll do we'll have a
field add a field where a user can
manually put in that that URL at least
that that last part of the URL and then
on the react side we can check so for
our href here we'll actually have a turn
area and it will check to see if we
actually received a value for that URL
if we did it'll use that if we did not
then maybe it'll fall back to something
like this I would really rather have
that work automatically but
just given given the complexity of the
URLs and the fact that they're not they
don't really all follow the same pattern
as you know if you've watched the
previous episodes which I'm sure you've
seen that I'm just not sure that there's
a way to if not only around you know
having users put in manually here's what
the URL needs to be for this piece of
content that that should solve yeah
that's just solve that problem it should
solve our search problem I think yeah
so that's probably what I'm gonna do to
fix that
normally I would go in and fix that so
it's but I'm just letting you know what
the next step is we may or may not do
that on a stream let me know if you'd be
interested in that that's probably going
to involve some PHP or at least finding
some sort of plugin that we can use I'm
having some issues right now where in
the past we've used advanced custom
fields which we could use here with the
API but the problem is I need to find
something that also works with WP graph
QL and advanced custom fields currently
does not work with WP graph QL so if I'm
gonna have a solution may as well find
one that works for everything I'd rather
not use advanced custom fields plug-in
just for the search and you know have
that whole plug-in there just for one
thing it'd be better to find a solution
that can work for everything if possible
let me check the chat I mean I'm
probably gonna have to wrap things up
here very soon so this is kind of a
frustrating stream for me I actually
didn't get anything done well I mean I
got I solved one error message that's
about it but just kind of unexpected
errors nikki says in the chat if we're
self hosting those fonts next Jess will
probably probably let you add the needed
loader to webpack for it to work okay
cool
Christopher says you should work on
replacing the loading with a loading
indicator yeah for sure I've you know
what I think I have an issue about that
on github right now
I don't know vaguely remember making
that issue so you know that's definitely
on the list
but yeah I mean I'd say that getting
this this.href right is probably the
most important thing right now for that
search because that's that's key
functionality right if user searching
for something they want to be able to
click on it and actually go to that page
so that needs to work everything else is
not necessary to work even the sorting
you know if we had to launch today I
could remove that sort look and just
leave it and for later but users need to
be able to click on those links so
that's priority number one for the
search page so that's definitely getting
done and then we're gonna we need to add
more more types so just to show you
before I wrap things up with the actual
fetch the WordPress comes built in with
this WordPress API it's a REST API and
the way you use this is you just have
your URL so here's your base URL which
is the URL to the WordPress site you add
on to the NW p - json / WP / v - and
then after that you can you basically
tell the api like hey here's all the
endpoints so i'm going to get data from
so we're using a plugin called multiple
post type which allows us to get data
from multiple post types but then that
also means we need to list all the post
types that we want so currently we are
adding by default Department major and
faculty but we have a ton of other types
so we need to include all those other
types and then also we can change what
types are added so in state we have
these check boxes right so we can change
which type is that we're searching for
okay and that's how we'll filter so this
definitely needs some additional info
here right now we are getting
per page which i think is reasonable
under per page the user can definitely
use filters to narrow that down and you
know I I think it'd be fine I mean think
about it we'll only gives you ten per
page and most people don't get passed on
most people don't get past that first
page but then after that it's very rare
for somebody to actually go through you
know 200 results right they have to go
through ten pages of search so I think
that should be fine and we may even want
to lower this really
all right and that's my 10-minute timer
just went off so I'm gonna check the
chat it looks like I don't have any more
questions so kind of slow day for the
chat kind of slow day for me too in
terms of what I'm getting done though
all right so yeah I'm gonna wrap things
up and see I kind of hope I don't have a
meeting but I do want to be prepared if
I do so if I do have a meeting I'm gonna
have to leave for that meeting in just a
few minutes so thank you all for joining
me definitely glad to be back I hope
that you're glad that I'm back to and
someone asked if I could flash the
folder structure so yeah let me there we
go
all right that's that's the structure
and you can check it out on github as
well so all of this code is available on
github the links in the description feel
free to open pull requests a for kit to
use it for whatever projects that that
you'd like deaf have a lot of issues
open right now if you want to work on
them that's that's awesome especially if
you're trying to get your first pull
requests in let me know make a comment
on an issue and I'd be more than happy
to work with you to help you get a pull
request in alright so I tomorrow is
pretty busy with meetings for me but I'm
gonna do my best to try to get a stream
in especially since I didn't stream at
all last week so hopefully I'll be able
to stream I'm not exactly sure what time
afternoon is gonna be bad for me so I'm
thinking maybe late morning I might be
able to get something in but I'll let
y'all know on Twitter and probably on
Instagram as well if you're subscribed
to this channel and you turn on
notifications you should get a
notification when I scheduled the stream
and it'll remind you again like a half
hour before the stream starts so I
definitely recommend that if you'd like
to see some other videos check out my
youtube channel the link is in the
description I do occasionally put some
videos and livestreams on there as well
let me thank you and that's it for me
thanks again for for joining me and for
let me know what you think in in the
chat I really appreciate that and I'll
see you all tomorrow until then have a
great day